hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I want to be
the guy guide and a lot of you have been
suggesting this and I got convinced to
play it when one of my actual real life
friends told me hey you gotta play this
game so here I am I actually fired it up
and I kind of have an idea of what I'm
gonna get into so let's see yeah that's
so what I saw I barely started the game
and things didn't go so well so I don't
even know the buttons - there we go okay
so I have a pretty good idea of what I'm
looking forward to ah this is gonna be
the worst this is gonna be the worst
this is gonna be so bad okay
ah AHA I don't have a knack aha
oh wait
Wow Lisa's gotta kill her try oh boy am
I gonna be able to get through oh I
don't know what I was expecting
ha ha so if I jump the bridge goes out
aah oh yeah aah [ __ ] holy piss ha ha yes
Wow
oh okay ah ah what's up [ __ ] oh this is
gonna be so bad
oh I jump too early yeah oh yeah yeah I
made it to the first level
no no okay what am i doing
will be of you he'll be AB you what am i
doing I can't think
Dube you aah aah aah Oh No
I actually hit the restart button sorry
moving forward
ooh I like the music the soundtrack is
amazing but I don't know what am i doing
what the are you [ __ ] ah you gotta be
kidding me
it's the worst it's like a long
drawn-out intro sequence of nothing and
I gotta make sure I time my ha
ah you [ __ ] oh man oh that oh that is
oh that that is wrong that's just wrong
oh god oh god oh god oh god made it I
see a save point
yeah oh man is it so no no no none ooh
ha ha ha ha I don't know what I was
expecting
it's gonna take me a while to get
through this part I hope you're all
ready and settled in I hope you got a
big bag of popcorn because this is gonna
take me a while whoo-ha mmm you all
right don't cross me don't Gregory ah ha
ha ha ha oh crap ha ha no you're gonna
fall down again I know you are
oh I saved ha ha ha
and wait maybe if I oh okay come on I
gotta get some here okay that went down
and now it's gonna go back up and then
the just giant fish that's right there
and I'm a pro da okay we're gonna do
this quick like Oh
quick we gotta do is quick ha giant fish
where's the giant fish hey where's that
giant fish ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha I
made it up two more thing easy that
gonna fall but he's gonna blow Tommy
what are you I got out fishy fishy fishy
Josh back this is all what I do
oh man is so bad so bye miss baby [ __ ]
ok w w ha ha killed you [ __ ] which one
of these is gonna explode ah can I make
it up there maybe ah ah damn it
okay not quite
ah Oh what the hell oh no [ __ ] hey my
life hey my life [ __ ] a stoppie hey my
life is so bad you suck oh that [ __ ]
alright so I gotta I gotta get up there
ah
oh I'm so close how ah how do I I don't
know I don't know I can't even make it
past the first part of the first level
let alone the first level oh man it's
like there's gotta be the worst I've
ever played in my life
let me is that my fault this game is
just rolling to the max I'm in first cat
Mario and then this son of a [ __ ]
I mean look at him smiling they're like
the [ __ ] that he knows he is i'ma get
Bryce a Damascus got a little idea being
brutally murdered
alright so what are we doing why is this
one in particular red I don't know I
don't know I don't know okay maybe maybe
the answer is obvious that I actually do
have to jump up here haha oh oh yeah ah
[ __ ] why ha ha is she a [ __ ] son of a a
bird ah
I'm gonna oh oh this game thinks hey
controlled my aha
Gretch that's right yes science [ __ ]
eww ha ha ha all right
but I still can I climb up pipes are
some there another but oh ah ha ha did
not know about that
wish I known about that earlier oh yeah
ha ha and really tell me oh ah ah oh ah
fat come on I'll get you fishy
ha ha missed me Oh miss me too oh you're
all missing me ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
magic you're [ __ ] at all
what are you gonna do about it ha ha ha
ha okay
huh oh [ __ ] I'm not gonna make that holy
hell
what do they want me to do uh uh okay
getting better getting getting better
getting better not better getting better
huh bro Dutch oh not pro Dutch oh oh oh
haha Pro dodge I bet this is exciting to
watch
ha ha what's that buddy oh you gonna
come here we go mmm mmm suck it [ __ ]
okay I need to like Swan oh oh I'm gonna
kill myself ah there I killed myself Oh
Oh God
oh this is oh this is hell this is what
hell is like
there's gotta be yeah oh fishy oh that's
a Mario fish I just noticed what's a
fish from Mario I didn't recognize it at
first you know because of all the me
dying die [ __ ] sink you're all camo and
[ __ ] you're not Oh neither are you ha oh
those uh-oh I'm stupid
ha oh we're young boom ba-ba-boom okay
don't miss what are you still alive wha
ah
hose it alive I shot him
uh past huh huh and why am I so
miniature by comparison ha ha okay blah
blah blah blah I gotta hit him multiple
times okay don't miss ha jump jump oh no
oh I just grappled I would have made
that [ __ ] oh god I'm so oh man huh
this is this is ah [ __ ]
now get back up here you [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ] you can't mess with me
I'm the strategy guide fake-out you're
here
don't worry kid I got the hook
oh gosh anyone know what I'm talking
about any other fans at egoraptor out
there he's a good guy
I like it ha ha ha job and gravel Wow
ha ha no I got it totes mix croats focus
mode oh I'll do my serious face what I
do when I'm like in the zone right to to
break it down I'll mow you down oh yeah
baby oh baby video huh huh huh huh huh
oh [ __ ]
not good enough ha ha oh man
I hope you guys are enjoying this
because is horrible look like beyond the
worst is this so far above and beyond
torture I can't even imagine like
putting up with this I mean ever Dark
Souls was bad but this is worse
there's gotta be worse I can't imagine
anything else being more ball-breaking
than this is ha ha yeah oh [ __ ] off you
wretch [ __ ] you ah
ah mother of [ __ ] hell wha I shot him
I shot him in de neige ha ha ha ha ha
okay ha there you go
suck it down [ __ ] ha ha I look familiar
yeah where have I been here before
ok alright out tough ok
ha ha ha ha huh
all right Myron
I gotta get to the next save point I got
a fine oh okay I gotta head out I wasn't
hahaha
what happened I fell off for no reason I
didn't even press the jump button
I didn't even jump I'm gonna fell off
[ __ ] game okay
alright calm down for a second calm down
markiplier you're being a little
irrational here don't you think
yeah okay that's how you lost your
medical license just to keep it nice and
calm Wow if I had to jumped if I just
swung back I would have been fine it
would have fell off into the ocean
Oh toast mix gross serious mode
alright oh so good nah Oh what the
[ __ ] hell Jesus my goodness it like
it's trying to kill me
at first I thought it was just joking
around affect you alright okay okay
I bet it didn't take you all this long
to get through this first level I bet I
really just do suck ha ha okay come on
come on ah come on jump down you [ __ ]
ha oh that was such a [ __ ]
oh no such [ __ ] I got tried again
after that I almost had it
I think I grappled onto his leg I don't
even know how it did that and when I
when I unraveled he like ported right on
top of me and squished me like bug
crispy like little ant I'm gonna assume
that all these commandos her Russian or
some no no no up up up ah yeah jump down
you [ __ ] oh oh my god oh no God
Oh Lebanon oh my god and with that I'm
done with this game forever
ah ha ha yeah I'm the best Oh
oh yeah everybody dance with me cuz I'm
so great I'm just the greatest oh look
at me let me go huh let me go oh yeah
okay all right so now we have
successfully beaten the game shut up we
beat the game where we beat the game
uh-oh
we beat it whole game beat good job
everybody thanks for the nice teamwork
thank you so much for being with me if
you really want a second part I guess
again no no no no no no I'm done okay so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done check the description for a link to
the game yourself and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye
Oh